[Musique]
avec nous maintenant eric girard
ministre des finances et de l'économie
et de l'innovation du québec bonsoir
monsieur girard bonsoir alors en lisant
le document aujourd'hui il ya deux
choses qui nous saute aux yeux aux yeux
bien sûr puis on vient d'en parler forte
croissance économique en début d'année
ainsi venu apporter plus de revenus mais
les dépenses sont moins grandes que
prévu d'un milliard 800 millions comment
ça s'explique ça précisément sur les
dépenses
mais d'abord il faut être conscient que
cette année ils ont les dépenses totales
devait être en hausse de 15% et il ya eu
des efforts extrêmement importants pour
faire face à la pandémie soutenir les
québécois donc plus de dépenses amène la
possibilité qu'on est moins deux des
plus de dépenses projetées à même de la
possibilité qu'on ait moins de dépenses
réalisées et historiquement au
gouvernement du québec le je vous dirai
dans les cinq dernières années on a une
moyenne annuelle de 2 milliards de
dépenses qui ne
ils ont réalisé qu'ils ne sont pas
réalisés examen puisque le déficit a
fondu de 15 à 12 à 10 milliards
elle reste quand même pas mal mais
est-ce que vous pouvez donc prévoir un
retour plus rapide au déficit zéro que
ce que vous que votre objectif actuel
qui est de 2000 27 28
c'est à ce stade si c'est prématuré là
parce que vraiment ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui c'est
donnez la mise à jour de l'année
financière qui s'est terminée 31 mars
bien sûr depuis que nous avons déposé le
budget plusieurs économistes ont révisé
à la hausse leurs prévisions de
croissance pour 2021
oui on a eu aussi l'annoncé d'un budget
fédéral des fonds associés aux
transferts pour services de bière et
pour l'enfant de 2021 est ce que vous
avez révisé à la hausse votre prison
croissance économique
c'est à dire qu'on oeuvre on ne révise
pas la croissance économique du budget
ce qu'ils avaient dans le budget c'était
quatre points de pourcent mais ce qu'on
voit c'est que le consensus des
économistes du secteur privé est plus
élevée avoisine presque 6% maintenant
monsieur girard que le déficit pourrait
être encore moins important qu'attendu
pour l'exercice actuel dans lequel nous
sommes présentement
oui c'est possible mais c'est tout dans
la nuit la fois inconscient on parlait
aussi de quatrième vague nécessité
d'accélérer la vaccination alors on
essaie tout dans le processus non mais
c'est pour jouer prudence mais c'est pas
le moment de réviser l'exercice 21 22 ça
se fait à l'automne et il faut regarder
aussi ce qui est vraiment important
c'est le déficit structurel qu'ont
estimé à 6.5 milliards
il va falloir
réviser ce chiffre à à l'automne lors de
la mise à jour mais donc est ce que ça
vaut encore la peine de faire un débat
sur la révision de la loi sur le retour
à l'équilibré budgétaire
pour vous donner finalement plus de
temps pour revenir à l'équilibré
je pense très important d'avoir le débat
de toute façon les finances publiques
appartiennent aux québécois
moi j'ai un rôle de fiduciaire mais il
sait à peu près certain qu'on va manquer
nous aussi de des points qui sont
décrites dans la loi sur la gestion de
la dette et fonds des générations
on va manquer nos cibles de dette donc
on doit avoir cette réflexion
et oui à ce stade si nous prévoyons
toujours revenir à l'équilibré
budgétaire
ensuite est-ce que la croissance passe
par la vaccination
au point de créer une loterie pour
encourager certains à se faire vacciner
c'est à dire que la sécurité saint tin
et nécessaire pour la croissance
économique
c'est indéniable on le dit à chaque
vague on y lisent enseignements qu'on a
eu dans la troisième vague nous ont
permis d'avoir plus d'activité que prévu
alors la loterie c'est une idée pour
stimuler ceux qui sont moins tentés
d'aller se faire vacciner et bien sûr le
tout serait éligible à la loterie de
tous c'est en discussion
ça s'en vient les discussions sont en
cours
ok je parle au ministre de l'économie
que vous êtes depuis quelques temps avec
trois semaines depuis trois semaines
pour combien de semaines encore on ne
sait pas on verra mais le ministre de
l'économique vous êtes peut-être nous
dire c'est quoi le point fort du québec
de l'économie du québec en ce moment
mais aussi le point faible de notre
économie
c'est vraiment une bonne question ce qui
est fort c'est la demande intérieure
alors la consommation est forte
l'investissement résidentiel la dépense
gouvernementale l'investissement privé
toutes les composantes de la demande
domestique sont fortes et le
déconfinement aide à cela le rebond de 2
est un autre élément ce qui là où on
doit faire mieux définitivement c'est au
niveau des exportations
on a accès à des marchés de 1.5 milliard
d'habitants avec l'accord avec l'europe
la libre échange canada mexique on doit
faire mieux au niveau des exportations
et notre capacité à faire mieux au
niveau des exportations va déterminer si
on va réussir notamment à augmenter le
pib potentiel du québec lorsqu'on essaie
de faire de 1.5 à 2 % à long terme et la
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre également
monsieur nominé c'est quand même un
ralentisseur de l'économie du québec ce
oui mais en fait
la pénurie ou la rareté de main-d'oeuvre
c'est important de dire aussi qu'elle
témoigne la force de l'économie
québécoise l'eau et la tendance lourde
c'est à dire le vieillissement de la
population mais on va attaquer ça on le
fait déjà de plusieurs manières d'abord
faut dire qu'on a 175 mille personnes ou
approximativement qui ne travaillent pas
présentement qui travaillait en février
2020 on voit ça dans tous les pays
industrialisés c'est normal d'avoir un
bassin de personnes qui travaillent pas
en même temps qu'on a des emplois
vacants il faut faire l'appariement et
ça c'est le travail de jean bulli le
ministre avec les qualifications
on a aussi au québec deux cent mille
jeunes de 15 à 34 ans qui sont ni aux
études ni en emploi ni en formation
et finalement on a en général les
québécois qui prennent leur retraite
trop tôt c'est qu'on a un bassin
potentiel de 90000 travail ans on avait
le même toute participation que
l'ontario chez les 55 ans et plus a
ajouté un seul immigration donc on a
plusieurs moyens pour s'attaquer à la
rareté mende
mais en attendant on est toujours à cent
cinquante mille postes vacants
présentement au québec
oui mais avec un chargé on encore vu les
chefferies hier qui grandissent dans un
premier trimestre à un autre premier
trimestre on a toujours de plus en plus
de postes vacants
oui mais en même temps je je je le
répète on ne s'en ressente 15000
personnes qui ne travaillent pour un qui
travaille en février alors cet
appariement l'eau entre ceux qui ne
travaillent pas et les pôles disponibles
c'est normal que ça se fasse pas
instantanément
monsieur mines et je vous souhaite une
bonne fête nationale merci merci
beaucoup merci aura je te plaisais pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne
r d